hello care with the outdoor boys YouTube
gentleman here with Nathan and we're
doing a super daily video with helium
[Music]
it was a little bit of a rough night
last night for the outter boys household
poor Tommy was throwing up despite my
wife being crippled and my boy throwing
up and me eating some old sushi which I
shouldn't have eaten it's been a pretty
decent week
Tommy's very first youtube video that he
did himself that his idea has gone
epically viral well this week
oh no Tommy's dead make sure to check
out Tommy's YouTube video also if you
guys like like seeing videos with Nate
and Tom just kind of them goofing around
being cute I've got a playlist just for
cute Nate and Tom videos
and if you can't get enough of the
outdoor boys YouTube channel check out
our other YouTube channel the catfish
and carp YouTube channel where we put
all of our fishing videos I'll put a
link in the descriptions for both those
a lot of people have been asking about
how Beck is doing and progress is really
slow we've got a physical therapist
coming over she's got some more doctor's
appointments but progress has been slow
however we've been trying to get out
more and just keep her from languishing
on the couch so we made a trip to
Walmart and it was super awesome because
we got to use the little electric
scooters which I have secretly wanted to
do for a very long time slow ride dude
do do do do to do to see take it easy
so Becca was a really good sport about
going out in public on her little
scooter also me and Nathan goofed around
a little bit with some helium balloons
this week and had a good time
hey Nathan how are you doing this
daddy's boy sounds silly
both Nathan and Tommy have been really
good big brothers and the other day we
were sitting on the couch and Tommy was
holding Jacob and he started singing him
this this lullaby your good singer of
lullabies yes Tommy what's your favorite
song to listen to on the radio
tell me you worked on docks that's also
my favorite so Tommy used to work by the
docks so if you guys can guess the name
and artist of that song and put it leave
a comment in the video description I
want to see how many of you get that
reference
do you like the Rasputin song they are
pretty funny you want me to get you
something to drink water okay I'll get
you some water
all right you guys like your drinks you
feel better now this last weekend we got
to do something fun we've never done
before we got to go to Monster Jam
yeah when we got to got to meet the
drivers of their favorite trucks now
Tommy what's your favorite monster truck
monster mutton Nathan who's your
favorite monster truck the zombie
monster truck yeah it was pretty cool we
I wanted to take the boys in video tape
monster jam you know just kind of do a
video log about going to Monster Jam but
you're not allowed to video it you know
there's some copyright issues sorry
contacted their PR representative and
they gave us backstage passes and and
the boys got to hang out in the drivers
dressing room and I got to interview the
driver of monster mutt and we got to go
out check out the go to the pit party
and then stay for the show and we just
had a real ball so I got a video coming
out soon well I'll show you guys all
that fun we had read Monster Jam
oh it's also been a really slow week for
fishing we've been having a lot of ice
where I'm at and the cabin fever got a
little bit Timmy this last week tried to
take Tommy out fishing and it was it was
a lot of work
also me and the family we're super
excited about sub or 2018 I'm taking
about a month off the entire month of
July actually from the law firm and we
are going to be just traveling and
shooting videos but haven't planned out
everything but last night we bought 26
airline tickets so when you have a
family of five traveling traveling the
world for a month it apparently requires
a lot of airline tickets if you have
some ideas of things you'd like to see
us do let us know we're gonna we're
gonna be all over Utah we're gonna be in
British Columbia Canada we're gonna be
in Washington State
we're gonna be in kyoto and osaka japan
on Honshu so if you have any ideas of
things you'd like to see the let us know
alrighty
alright so got Jakob here let's go take
him downstairs with the boys there you
go
didn't even wake up well guys I am
utterly convinced that being into
hunting and fishing makes you a better
father and husband because if you can
stick your hands at the chest cavity of
a dead deer for fun then picking pasta
out of bed sheets no problem do dirty
diaper explosions anytime ya know what I
mean being squeamish just isn't a plus
when it comes to parenting well guys
we've got a physical therapist coming to
the house and about an hour and this
place looks like a bomb went off so I'm
gonna put down the camera and feed some
kids clean the house and just do my
husbandly duty can't coast on my good
looks forever stay tuned we've got a lot
of awesome videos coming your way some
more axe restoration stuff tent review
videos some survivalist gear and some
really fun adventures with the boys
help you enjoy this video with me and
Nathan here if you'd like to see more
great videos from the outer our boys
YouTube channel don't forget to
subscribe thanks for watching we hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you'd
like to see more great videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video